[Music]
people are worried
for leonardo dicaprio's girlfriend as
she celebrates her 25th birthday oh he's
gonna dump her right that's his theme
once the model
i love everyone's quick acceptance of
this understanding yeah yeah 25 is just
way too old
he doesn't want rotten meat
he just wants the premium he doesn't
want dry aged okay guys going after veal
and beetle only
there's a there's a lot there's a lot
going for him so he doesn't have to
accept what we have to yeah dude he has
to worry about the environment
you know what he does he does have to
worry about the environment if he didn't
worry about the environment
a different thing but this guy's trying
to save the planet you think it's
because the planet's aging his
girlfriend's too too quickly
the sun the uv rays and everything
got to keep him happy man whatever he
wants what's your favorite leo movie
titanic 2 by far israel new york did you
do a backstory i was like electric
boogaloo
because i missed out on so many movies
i'm like dude they came out with another
one i think what is it what what do you
think the plot line of titanic 2 is
they're trying to find the [ __ ]
necklace there's some [ __ ] like that
they're trying out the plotline of
titanic one no no or they try to rebuild
another one and then that one fails
again unfreeze jack from the bottom of
the thing he goes and seeks revenge i
don't even want titanic they don't
unfreeze him they call him jack frost
that's what he's saying that's called
titanic two judgment day
[Laughter]
sarah o'connor was on the ship yeah
yo that makes sense she's irish
o'connor
o'connor or was it just connor no john i
think it was just connor i said okay
my two favorite leo films i think is
inception and the departed oh
interesting choices gang's in new york
inception's really great gangster are
[ __ ] amazing i'll say inception as
well gangs i mean uh departed i have one
of those um cause you know how was it
infernal affairs before it was it
departed so anytime things like that
happen like those major attitudes you
judge it yeah i judge it a little bit a
little bit like i've seen it before part
that i like though is uh that i don't
know if infernal affairs goes deep into
it because i don't know if that's part
of asian cinema or they do like deep
character work where leo is seeing the
uh the therapist
and you can see him frantically go like
oh [ __ ] what the [ __ ] do i do like
because they're burning his file on this
side they're banning him on this side
and he's really like [ __ ] desperate
and i was like oh [ __ ] that was cool
i'll give you that yeah i enjoyed in the
infernal affair uh version them tapping
the key on the pipes in order to do
morse code for the detect to find it
versus him texting in his uh uh but with
t9 you could do that i kind of like that
though i like seeing that i like seeing
that thing where they just like went
inside like a bag then like film the
phone screen you could play snake in
your pocket back then yeah is that what
you did
what's your ryan what's your favorite i
did it without a phone what's your
favorite it's my favorite leo movie
basketball diaries is okay
i don't think i've seen that one it's a
good one damn
they missed that
it just keeps getting bigger
you want to say it again
yes okay a third time or that word from
the top straight stake in my pocket
without a phone
oh it's not funny the third time
dripping the cheese
that's the style we're looking for you
guys are all wrong it's gilbert grape
what's eating gilbert that's the best
wheel that's good yeah that's not i i
really liked wall street
yeah
i think he's having fun in wolf of wall
street too it looks like he's yeah he's
sniffing cocaine off marvel robbie's
tits yeah must be fun marco robbie in
that [ __ ] movie hey we got a new
crush for husso
off camera you're doing a really good
uh gilbert grape impression do you want
to do it right now
off camera off camera he did it he was
doing so good right when you came in
with the coffees you were like playing
it up i haven't even seen gilbert great
what's eating your great i know that's
what makes it amazing yeah yeah but
that's why your impression was so good
it was so spot-on what's the movie about
again it's sad right we just don't want
you to have a career for 20 years
he goes like
oh good gilbert he
which super model is he dating now a
great transition barbie yeah so um yeah
so her name is model camilla marone i
guess she has three million followers
she literally just turned a quarter
century that she wrote this on instagram
you have a picture of her she probably
looks hella old by now oh my god 25
jesus
she's a [ __ ] dinosaur something
happens to women
qualify for aarp yet
she got some aggressive eyebrows which
one this is some eyebrows yeah i could
see her aging dude she's she's getting
old bro she looks like a woman and that
might be too old for him she looks legal
so like that's probably a step in the
right direction seeing her sit next to
leo's kind of wild well she she looks
like she's
just one day away from trying to nag and
[ __ ]
that's what it really is
that's what it really is this is another
one of those things when he just reacted
and then he thought about what
what what feature on her on her looks is
like just the first 25 the first line of
like crow's feet it's like
can you do this and he's like oh [ __ ]
shut the [ __ ] up
each line is a complaint
yeah it's like [ __ ] karate each one's
a [ __ ] new degree all third degree
complainer
so the more she gets the more advanced
she is yeah dude yeah like through the
stripes on the belt how old is leo leo's
47 years old he's not even 50 yet oh
[ __ ] i thought he was older i thought he
was older why didn't this whole time i
thought he was in his 50s me too because
i think they make a big deal about dad
bod and like him being like older and
[ __ ] brad pitt is like almost 60 huh
yeah yeah wow but he kind of looks it
yeah he kind of looks it leo and camilla
have been dating since 2017 i mean she
was 20 when they got together was a long
term
that's a long-term relationship
four years especially in hollywood
though that's a chunk of time so he's
never dated anyone older than 25
apparently really but then he kept aging
except for his girls
yeah
yeah but i i guess like
in some point of the world
that's cool
he deserves to like we like in the yacht
world right yeah yeah i mean
it being legal it's just it's i guess
it's weird but i mean it's dark like
they do it so much too empathize though
i would hate to be her try to celebrate
my birthday oh yeah all the comments
it's just like oh you got to get dumped
because you're too old
they have a whole [ __ ] article about
it that sucks to have like everybody
talking about you that way
we're doing like a video
at least we're satirizing it like i
don't really think it's you know
especially since she's a girl
she's probably been going like that's
not true right
you're not gonna break up with me right
third degree third degree no but she's
25 so she talks she talks better than
that now and it's the turn off
she talks like a normal adult yeah he's
like oh
shut up
so what's the uh
the age gap for y'all what's the age gap
for y'all you know we've asked this
before but now that we're seeing leo
which is like one of the greats and he's
got a 27 year uh 22 year age gap what's
the age gap for you
that's wild you gotta you say it and
then we'll all
chime in like four to five years
[Laughter]
i need that [ __ ] insurance what
happened with the pony express
[Laughter]
i'm just so many expressions
tell me again about telegrams got such a
good system who shot kennedy
what's this new pager [ __ ]
were you there when it happened where
were you
now everyone's doing this technological
[ __ ] like morse code and it's like [ __ ]
man
gotta go to the station and send a
telegram so advanced that's some next
level [ __ ] less than less than 10 years
for me
less than 10. i can't i can't get to a
10-year gap that feels too big for me
the older i get the younger they can
become dude what do they even talk about
20-year gap you know that's pretty wild
but what if you're like 20 years within
like you're like the same generation i
think that's like my mom and my step-dad
oh really man he's a [ __ ] old piece
of [ __ ] he's like 87. how old is she
how's your husband she's like mid-70s or
late 70s i mean it's almost 20 years
when you're like 70 years old can you
see yourself being with like a 45 year
old i don't know about that those ages
are both old to me that's what i'm
saying like it's like a contestant
and then you have a young hot wife
that's 60
you know that's like scoring bro i know
are you living you're a pedophile but
damn still yeah as if like every single
day you're on the judgment block it's
like hey just remember when you were 20
she was embryo yeah i know
i think i think people get
weird because it's 20 because it's way
closer to 18 and below than anything
else but even 18 is the legal line
but i'm saying it's this country but
it's younger yeah but imagine yourself
going after an 18 year old you're just
like yeah because you're like
i'm
we can't get on this train again bro
we're gonna get this [ __ ] video
deleted again it can't go down this
[ __ ] road and that's patreon
[Music]
you